fear is a tool
when that light hits the sky
[Music]
it's not just a call
it's a warning
i'm vengeance
you see
many events have happened in history
that we look back at now
and we realize
we could have changed if things had been
different
isn't it very very interesting that we
are living in a time
where such an event is happening now
and it is happening to a people
in a country like china
whereby women are being raped
children are being separated from their
families
organs are being harvested
people are being put into concentration
camps
and did they think
that we were just going to stand idly by
[Music]
i want to tell the chinese government
and the chinese communist party one
thing
i want to tell you directly
you may be able to manipulate
governments
but you cannot manipulate the millions
of muslims around the world
did you think
that you are going to have a minority
group
in your country
persecute them in the way that you are
persecuting them
deal with them in the way that you are
dealing with them
and that we
were not going to get involved
do you think
that if you start war
if you start a war with the uyghurs
that you have not started at war with
the muslims
[Applause]
i tell the chinese today
with all violence in all figure
you have started a war with the muslims
and we will not live or die until we
become victorious in this
look at world now
look at them looking at me what are you
looking at
my question is what the hell are you
you've taken your flag away
while i have a flag that you can replace
your flag with
take this ring of flag you saw them
[__] me
i tell you today
you have nothing to offer the world
you have nothing at all to offer the
world you know why because you have
already incorporated a marxist communist
system you've already lost the war
against the americans and the west
because you have taken their ideology
but let me tell you something
your best bet is actually to become
muslims
that's your best bet your best bet is to
do what the mongols did and embrace
islam
you have nothing to do with the world
you have nothing to offer the world at
all
what happens if you become a superpower
tell me what happens when you become a
superpower in this cold war that you
want to get into with the americans
what have you got to offer the rest of
the world you've already taken their
ideologies marxism leninism you are
nothing i tell you you are nothing
and it's only a matter of time
it's only a matter of time until we deal
with you don't mean
that you cannot beat and defeat an enemy
that when they look at the barrel the
bottom of the barrel of the gun
they see paradise
we don't care about death in fact
we don't care about martyrdom please
make us marchers you cannot
[Music]
you should actually learn from them the
purpose of life to worship one god
you should learn from them
not to worship statues
and i tell you today
that you may be taken off
from the tops of the masjids and
replacing it with your communist flag
the flag of your ideological masters
but taking off the message does not mean
taking it out of the hearts of the
believers
[Applause]
so i tell you once and again
it's only a matter of time
and you may want to start this cold war
with america which you're starting now
having
the muslims as your enemies is not a
good idea
and history as it had in the past with
the persians and the romans on the
mongols and all of these
history will tell this story again and
you will be defeated
[Music]
together i don't know much about wigan
culture
but i know one thing that we are here
for the uyghurs and we will not rest
until justice is served
you